the fact that Mars is
Within Reach broadly
and chemical Rockets correct of current
technology of current physics and we do
it
hooray super hard we did it into
planetary right but your point is that
oh it seems like uh that is
insufficient
and also kind of like a false duck type
scenario where
we did it but we didn't actually do the
thing we needed to do so we may have
even been better off had the nearest
closest planet been two light years away
so Mars didn't exist correct and assume
that Elon was still the Visionary that
we want him to be
and he didn't have a chemical rocket
company
I'd like to think that he would be
focused on physics
I would like to think that any of these
people would be focused on physics
take anybody with 11 figures
what is your allocation to building a
life raft to get humans out of here
you don't you haven't even thought about
it
immediately you're going to think
technology well what kind of a hole
would I need it's like no
you need a Blackboard
you need blackboards and physicists who
are not afraid to do physics right now
we are destroying the fundamental
physics community at a rate that you
could not believe what's happening give
me the gossip from inside
for 39 years
we have been dominated by one
community's Madness
and that Community is called quantum
gravity
String Theory or M Theory
it changed what we were researching it's
it's cardinal sin is not about String
Theory it's not about quantum gravity it
changed the questions that met defined
what it meant to be a fundamental
physicist
so if I say to you how many generations
of matter are there
I don't know you don't know that it's
three because we don't talk about that
all the time anymore
or if I say do you know why why is
matter chiral you wouldn't know about
that or if I said what's the nature of
the cortic potential for the Higgs field
or why is there a yukawa coupling in one
case in a minimal coupling somewhere
else all of the real physics questions
that would cause
progress got
subtly replaced between 1984 and like
1987. and then we had questions like how
do we quantize gravity
and that became this oh that is the
ultimate question well it's it's not
that's that's just wrong this comes out
of Bryce DeWitt this comes out of a guy
who in 1952 went with his wife to the
Tata Institute of fundamental research
in Bombay then wrote an essay for
something called the Gravity Research
Foundation that was about anti-gravity
and they he was supposed to write an
essay and then he said well to get
anti-gravity what you'd really need to
do is to do quantum gravity and for 70
years we've been trying to do quantum
gravity and it's an abject failure
and the physicists at the at the helm
changed the questions the official
questions should sound something like
this why are there three generations of
matter why is it flavor chiral what is
the nature in the origin of the Higgs
mechanism
why are we in one comma three dimensions
and what is with su3 cross su2 cross U1
which is a bunch of symmetries and why
does it seem to represent on a 16
dimensional space with the observed
quantum numbers that may not mean a lot
to you but I guarantee you if they're a
physicists in the audience they're
getting pissed off right now because
they allowed their their subject to be
dragged away from our real questions for
reasons that are unclear and put in the
service of these questions that can't be
answered and we can't even question them
39 years into this complete train wreck
that is the community that could build
the life raft what is so seductive about
Quantum everything quantum gravity yeah
it allows for toy problems so that you
can not do your
work on the world that we have and you
can say well the world that we have is
too complicated so I created this fake
world over here that's not in four
dimensions it's in two Dimensions it's
not in laurencian signature it's in
euclidean signature it's not the full
gauge group uh it's just su2 and I've
changed all the parameters and then I
say and I've made some minor incremental
progress in that fake world and then
everybody claps
and meanwhile
10 years later you don't even remember
what the particles are that are present
in the universe you don't even remember
the the standard model of particle
theory and this is a very real effect
today's physicists a lot of the young
ones are completely ignorant about the
physical world they could not find the
men's or women's room at CERN uh if
they're life depended on them
yeah so it seems like
a hijacking of attention and focus
from
difficult problems
to from useful difficult problems to
useless or less useful
easier problems but if you try to talk
about the real problems you can't get
engagement and they will say it is well
maybe people just aren't interested in
your ideas I was like yeah but you're
not listening to so far as I can tell
everybody who comes from outside with an
interesting new idea isn't being
listened to it's not personal
and we also have a responsibility this
is like it's a really crazy part
we doomed Humanity
like Francis Crick
who was a co-discover of the
three-dimensional structure of DNA was a
physicist
Edward Teller was a physicist stanislav
ulam was a geometer
we doomed Humanity on Earth
and then we're treating science as if oh
it's a series of puzzles
well what do you want to work on today
well I don't want to be arrogant I'll
just work on this tiny little problem
and I'm just thinking like do do you not
feel any basic responsibility after
Hiroshima and Nagasaki and kovid
all right just how crazy are you is that
you know we've spoken about the
interplanetary
challenge right and the fact that
physics needs to make some progress in
order to facilitate that if we're going
to do it yeah is in your opinion
forgetting the fact that chemical
Rockets right limitations all that sort
of stuff
is going into planetary as useful is it
the highest priority the highest
priority
you'll you cannot stabilize this place
just imagine every communalist dream
came true
we turned away from fossil fuels towards
a the greenest New Deal you could
possibly imagine
all billionaires realize the errors of
their ways and contributed their money
to bring up the poorest of the poor
AI was as beneficial as it could be and
only helped Humanity to live its Street
just go full
wild Pollyanna optimism
you still can't stabilize it why
um
too many people
say more not for long population rates
both rights at the moment we're talking
at totally different scales
I'm telling you that with
crispr cas9 with the teller ulam design
ivg
you know ivg IVF but being able to use
from any other sure yep uh so I was
trying to I was trying to think uh in a
different context
you are going to have
um
people
what happens when you distribute the
coronavirus because everybody's had it
you've had it
I got an antibody test and I had it but
never failed it okay yeah so you have
this this pla platform this virus viral
platform that's spread all over the
world and you have the ability to edit
it
are you telling me that people aren't
going to figure out how to come up with
fun viruses and gain a function projects
and people are going to be able to do
these uh you know
polymerase Chain Reaction I think was
taught in my daughter's High School
are you familiar with uh Nick bostrom's
Bulls from the urn analogy yeah vaguely
yeah so for the people that don't know
you can imagine that you you have an urn
and each time that you make
technological progress you pick a ball
out and you don't know what color some
are white perfectly good yep so I'm a
gray bit a good bit of bad and some are
all the way down to black and black is
permanent unrecoverable collapse right
and the unrecoverable bit is important
no
and each time we just keep picking out
balls so my take on it is
there's already too much level too much
leverage too little wisdom too many
people was that you once said uh we are
Gods but for the wisdom we're just
shitty gods
I don't know if it's the second part but
um
you know I I guess when I heard the
story about this kid who scavenged the
americium from all of these smoke
detectors in Brooklyn and built a
self-sustaining nuclear reactor from
these tiny little radioactive strips you
don't know what people's creativity is
you know
I found it fascinating when I was
growing up that I was the only kid who
knew that gunpowder or black powder was
75 potassium nitrate
10 sulfur and 15 carbon like you could
just make it
you know
and
you know that's the recipe and
that that just blew my mind that the
rate limiting step was that
people didn't know that potassium
nitrate was saltpeter or where to get it
like meat tender but
mostly we're saved from the stuff
because nobody's so sociopathic and
competent
that they go for these high leverage
attacks that's going to end
you know that was like what happened on
9 11. I always wanted to know why were
little kids allowed to go into the
cockpit of a plane you used to be able
to meet the pilot I remember meeting
them I remember doing it yeah so that's
where we are now is is that we've got
all this High leverage stuff and you're
going to see nuclear proliferation
eventually you're going to get some
desperate backed into a corner
who says well this is my only move well
I mean
for the nuclear concernists out there at
least what I know wouldn't that be all
of us everybody is concerned but for the
people that are nuclear war is a genuine
X risk permanent and recoverable
collapse you can set them all off unless
there's like
10 to 100 times more than we think that
we have which there very well could be
um
it seems difficult for it to be
permanent unrecoverable collapse for me
as a true true true extras may I say
something yeah this is ridiculous
it's bad enough
that it would completely transform Life
as we know it you'd agree that
absolutely absolutely
it's time it's time to get serious about
things we can actually do and the most
interesting thing is that nobody's
interested
in interplanetary physics
I I just I've never seen anything like
it
interplanetary physics would be physics
in service of us becoming interplanetary
or is there something specific about the
way the planets figure together no no
it's it's about
but let me give you an analogy that's
more than an analogy assume that
somebody hands you
a physical paper map
an enormous one okay
and you're trying to navigate it on this
table that we're we have here
you're starting to do Motions like this
where you're moving the paper across the
table you know to get from Los Angeles
to Fresno California if it's at the
right scale and it might take you a long
time to do that
okay but now you have somebody trained
on an iPad what are they going to do
well they might do that but that's not
the key thing they're going to do
they're going to do what is called multi
multi-touch gestures
and the one that you're thinking of
should be pinched to zoom
so the most natural way to do this is to
treat it not as if it's a paper map but
a stack of paper maps and you want to go
to the one with a different scale if if
you were doing this on an iPad that was
mirroring this the key point is is that
the paper map doesn't have an extra
Dimension to play with but the pinch to
zoom dimension
is a scale Dimension so imagine what you
did instead was you looked at your house
you pinch to zoom out
you then do this motion or whatever it
is to get to your friend's house and
then when you land there
you expand it again
imagine that you only know about paper
maps but your adversary has an iPad
that's what I'm worried about
we're not looking for pinch to zoom
what would that be in this
um well I claim that there are going to
be 10 extra coordinates and
four of them
uh are pinched to zoom
and six of them are what I would call
um
Shear to tilt so imagine that you have a
copy of a picture of of the Leaning
Tower of Pisa on your iPad
you should be able to do something in
paint which changes the angle
right so if you go into Ms paint there's
this little thing that allows you to
change by a particular but you could do
that as a gesture where
so my claim is if you have four
dimensions of time and X Y and Z of
space
you have pinched to zoom on all of all
four of those and then for any two
Dimensions like x and z
you have Shear to tilt
so the first are the four rulers and the
next are the six protractors and that's
something called a symmetric two tensor
or a metric which Einstein knew all
about but he only chose one through his
equations and he let all the other ones
lie Fallout and my claim is I don't
think that's where we are I think that
interplanetary physics is going to
involve moving from what we called space
time to something called The Observers
which contains pinch to zoom and Shear
to tilt
and you want to get off this planet
you're not going to get there using
general relativity and you're not going
to get there using the standard model
it's time to take your pacifier out of
your mouth and go back to doing real
physics
I think if we were serious about this
we would be struggling with the physics
of the world in which we live not toy
models we'd be taking massive risks and
listening to people from various
perspectives who haven't failed or have
not been invited to fully explain their
ideas and we'd be looking for things
that would be
new new variables new ways of working
with the world that allowed us to do
things that would previously considered
inconceivable so if you if you look at
1911 which is when I think Rutherford
first starts talking about the neutron
as a hypothesis
it's 41 years later we have the hydrogen
bomb
we can do incredible things that are not
possible
yet because we don't know the framework
and my claim is
if you imagine somebody used to paper
maps being put on an iPad
and not knowing about multi-touch
gestures that is pretty much an exact
analogy of what happens when you do too
much general relativity is that you
start to think in general relativistic
terms as if that's the last word
Einstein would never have put up with
that we'll get back to talking to Eric
in one minute but first I need to tell
you about cozyoth look we spend one
third of Our Lives asleep you do not
want to spend 33 percent of your
existence inside of sheets that do not
make you feel amazing cozy Earth has the
best quality betting it's not just about
what you sleep on it is what you sleep
under and the quality of your sheets
make a massive difference to the quality
of your sleep sleep is the Ultimate Game
Changer and improving your sheets will
improve your Sleep Quality cozy Earth is
a premium bedding and loungewear Company
where they make the best quality bedware
the products are made from super soft
viscose from highly sustainable bamboo a
temperature regulating so you'll sleep
cool all year round best of all they've
got a 10 year warranty on all of their
products that's how confident they are
that they'll last you can get an extra
exclusive 35 discount site-wide on
everything from cozy Earth by going to
cozyearth.com Modern wisdom and using
the code modern wisdom 35 a check out
cozyearth.com modern wisdom and modern
wisdom a checkout thank you very much
for tuning in if you enjoyed that clip
with Eric then press here for the full
length three hour episode
go on
press it